Générique
- Alexandre Poussart: Bonjour à
tous.
Très heureux de vous retrouver
pour un nouveau numéro de
"Parlement hebdo".
- Kathia Gilder: Nous accueillons
cette semaine Violette Spillebout.
Merci d'être avec nous.
Vous êtes députée Renaissance du
nord.
- Alexandre Poussart: On va parler
de l'agenda parlementaire qui
commence à se préciser.
Une série de réformes qui ont un
objectif pour le gouvernement:
tourner la page de la réforme des
retraites alors que la
mobilisation se poursuit dans la
rue.
Face aux violences dans les
manifestations, la majorité
présidentielle à l'Assemblée
nationale souhaite une commission
d'enquête sur les casseurs.
Les députés Insoumis dénoncent une
initiative qui détourne le regard
des violences policières.
Le Sénat va ouvrir une commission
d'enquête qui va viser le fonds
Marianne.
L'argent de ce fonds aurait été
mal utilisé, notamment à des fins
politiques.
Le parquet national financier a
ouvert une information judiciaire
pour détournement de fonds
publics.
- Kathia Gilder: On commence par
cette question.
Quelle marge de manoeuvre le
gouvernement a-t-il au Parlement
après la réforme des retraites qui
a accaparé députés et sénateurs?
Plusieurs textes sont à l'ordre du
jour jusqu'à la mi-juillet.
Budget des armées, emploi ou
encore RSA.
Les détails.
- Dès la semaine prochaine, en
commission, les députés
examineront la loi de
programmation militaire.
413 milliards d'euros de dépenses
entre 2024 et 2030.
Un objectif ambitieux: transformer
les armées françaises.
Autre projet de loi présenté à la
mi-mai, celui sur l'industrie
verte.
Faciliter les ouvertures d'usine
tout en poussant à la
décarbonation de l'industrie.
Examen prévu à l'été.
Le gouvernement souhaite par
ailleurs mettre à l'ordre du jour
rapidement la loi sur le partage
de la valeur, une transposition de
l'accord entre patronat et
syndicats pour généraliser les
dispositifs comme l'intéressement,
la participation ou encore
l'actionnariat salarié à toutes
les entreprises de plus de 11
personnes.
Un texte plein emploi est prévu
d'ici le mois de juin.
Pôle emploi deviendra France
travail pour inciter au retour à
l'emploi, le RSA et le revenu de
solidarité active seront
conditionnés à une quinzaine
d'heures d'activité par semaine.
Une mesure déjà critiquée.
Le gouvernement travaille enfin à
un texte plus large sur le travail
qui pourrait réintégrer les
mesures de la réforme des
retraites, censurées par le
Conseil constitutionnel.
Le projet de loi immigration est
reporté à l'automne.
Le temps d'essayer de dégager une
majorité avec la droite,
notamment.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que vous
pensez que cet agenda
parlementaire est de nature à
apaiser le pays alors que la
mobilisation dans la rue se
poursuit contre la réforme des
retraites?
Une majorité de Français la
soutient.
Est-ce que c'est le bon agenda et
le bon moment?
- Violette Spillebout: C'est un
agenda qui pour moi,
politiquement, va apaiser les
choses.
Il va se concentrer sur des
grandes priorités pour les
Français.
Vous parliez tout à l'heure de la
loi sur la décarbonation de
l'industrie.
C'est un vrai enjeu d'urgence de
transition écologique.
C'est quelque chose de rassembleur
qui va mobiliser les chefs
d'entreprise, les employés, les
jeunes et tous ceux qui veulent
qu'on ait une économie moins
polluante demain.
Ca va être un projet passionnant.
- Kathia Gilder: C'est ce que les
Français attendent?
- Violette Spillebout: On a un
autre texte qui est attendu.
C'est celui de l'immigration.
L'immigration, on doit traiter ce
sujet.
Le fait qu'il y ait eu le report à
la rentrée, c'est un signe
d'apaisement.
On a besoin, puisqu'on doit
accélérer sur beaucoup de
réformes, de trois mois, jusqu'à
l'été, on va travailler vite.
Quand on voit tous ces projets de
loi, au Parlement, on sait qu'on
va accélérer.
Il y a le projet de loi sur le
travail, sur le RSA, mais il y a
aussi le numérique, les
influenceurs, la loi sur le
partage de la valeur qui va nous
mobiliser fortement...
Il y a beaucoup de sujets sur
lesquels on va devoir être
efficaces.
- Alexandre Poussart: D'abord, une
question sur la réforme des
retraites.
On est toujours dans une séquence
de mobilisation sociale assez
forte contre ce texte.
Cette semaine, la deuxième demande
de référendum d'initiative
partagée sur la réforme des
retraites a été rejetée par le
Conseil constitutionnel.
Est-ce que demander l'avis aux
Français, ça n'aurait pas été une
solution pour sortir de cette
crise sociale?
- Violette Spillebout: Je crois
que nos oppositions ont tenté
l'ensemble des voies démocratiques
institutionnelles pour contester
cette réforme.
On a passé plusieurs étapes: le
vote à l'Assemblée, au Sénat, les
propositions de référendum...
Aujourd'hui, c'est rejeté.
On souhaite continuer de
travailler sur tous les sujets qui
ont été soulevés.
Les trois étapes des lois sur le
travail vont aborder les
conditions de vie au travail, la
qualité de vie au travail,
l'égalité...
Ce sont des sujets qu'on
n'abandonne pas et qui vont nous
occuper.
- Kathia Gilder: En attendant,
contre cette réforme des
retraites, il y a une initiative
le 8 juin, une proposition de loi
pour abroger l'article qui fait
passer l'âge de la retraite de 60
à 64 ans.
Est-ce que si cette proposition de
loi était adoptée, Emmanuel Macron
devrait renoncer à appliquer sa
réforme?
- Violette Spillebout: Si cette
proposition de loi était adoptée
le 8 juin, elle serait adoptée à
l'Assemblée et elle passerait
ensuite au Sénat.
On rentrerait à nouveau dans un
cycle parlementaire nouveau.
J'espère qu'elle ne sera pas
adoptée.
On a une responsabilité sur
l'enjeu de l'équilibre de notre
système de retraite et de sa
préservation.
- Kathia Gilder: L'opposition ne
lâche pas la bataille.
- Violette Spillebout: Nous non
plus.
On va être très mobilisés le 8
juin.
On a eu 15 jours de pause dans
l'hémicycle, ce qui nous a permis
d'être dans nos circonscriptions.
Il y a beaucoup d'autres sujets
que les retraites qui préoccupent.
Mais le 8 juin, nous serons au
complet.
- Alexandre Poussart:
Démocratiquement, en cas de rejet
par l'Assemblée nationale de cette
réforme des retraites, est-ce que
ce serait un coup dur?
Il faudrait renoncer à appliquer
ce texte?
- Violette Spillebout: Il faut
qu'on maintienne une forme
d'humilité.
On est en majorité relative,
aujourd'hui.
Rien n'est simple.
Les voix des oppositions sont
fortes.
On le voit très régulièrement.
- Kathia Gilder: Vous les prenez
en compte?
- Violette Spillebout: On les
prend en compte.
Il y a beaucoup de projets de loi,
dans ces échanges un peu brutaux,
qui évoluent.
Tout ça, ça montre que les voix
des Français sont représentées à
l'Assemblée.
- Alexandre Poussart: Jeudi, en
une seule journée, les députés
d'opposition ont réussi à faire
voter une proposition de loi qui
abroge l'obligation vaccinale des
soignants contre le Covid et une
autre proposition de loi sur EDF
qui élargit le bouclier tarifaire
sur l'électricité aux artisans,
aux PME, à certaines collectivités
territoriales.
Cela fait une dépense
supplémentaire de 11 milliards
d'euros.
Une sorte de victoire pour les
oppositions.
- Les boulangers sont dans le
pétrin.
Les boulangers, comme les
artisans, comme les PME, comme les
toutes petites entreprises, sont
confrontés à l'explosion du prix
de l'énergie qui fragilise leur
existence, qui fragilise leur
compétitivité pour ce qui concerne
nos industries, nos PME et nos
TPE, ça justifie que nous
puissions non pas ouvrir la boîte
de Pandore de la dépense publique
pour être à leur chevet, mais
d'être efficaces.
- Alexandre Poussart: Finalement,
ces 100 jours commencent par une
défaite politique pour le
gouvernement?
- Violette Spillebout: Ce vote,
hier, pour moi, il est symbolique
d'une victoire d'une alliance
NUPES et Rassemblement National.
Sur le plan politique, restons
raisonnables.
On voit bien que l'engagement du
président de la République, du
gouvernement, c'est d'avoir 100 %
des actions d'EDF, c'est de
protéger EDF et d'en faire le
leader mondial de l'énergie, que
ce soit de sa production, de sa
distribution et de sa fourniture.
Ca veut dire aussi une nouvelle
programmation du nucléaire.
Ce sont des ambitions très fortes.
Ce projet de loi a très peu parlé
de la transformation d'EDF.
C'était un peu la bonne excuse
pour évoquer plein d'autres sujets
sur lesquels il y avait des
propositions un peu démagogiques
de l'ensemble des oppositions.
Il fait la navette.
Il a déjà fait le Sénat,
l'Assemblée nationale.
Il va repartir en deuxième
lecture.
On voit aussi que c'est une
dépense publique de 11 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires au profit
des PME, des collectivités...
- Kathia Gilder: C'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour ces petites
entreprises qui souffrent parfois
terriblement de l'inflation?
- Violette Spillebout: Sur ma
circonscription, j'ai été beaucoup
sollicitée depuis Noël sur les
sujets énergétiques des TPE, mais
aussi des PME.
Moi, je l'ai vu, et l'ensemble de
mes collègues députés, à chaque
fois qu'il y avait une situation
particulière sur un contrat qui
avait été signé pour 24 mois au
pire moment du prix de
l'électricité, cette situation a
été prise en compte à la fois par
l'Etat par des aides spécifiques
et aussi par les fournisseurs
d'énergie qui ont été poussés à
faire des efforts particuliers.
Roland Lescure l'a redit dans
l'hémicycle: s'il y a une facture
qui a exposé d'une PME, ils vont
s'en occuper.
11 milliards d'euros, de façon
générale, pour étendre le tarif
réglementé, quand on voit la
situation des finances publiques,
c'est un vrai sujet.
- Alexandre Poussart: Dans cet
agenda parlementaire, le
gouvernement présentera un projet
de loi en juin pour le plein
emploi.
Un texte qui va conditionner le
RSA à 15 à 20h d'activité par
semaine.
- Violette Spillebout: C'est une
mesure sensible.
Mais c'est une mesure
indispensable aujourd'hui.
Ce qu'on veut, c'est que chaque
personne qui bénéficie du RSA,
puisse bénéficier d'un réel
accompagnement.
C'est-à-dire des moyens humains en
plus, des moyens financiers de
l'Etat pour accompagner à une
réinsertion de l'emploi.
Bien sûr, une femme qui vit seule
avec trois enfants en bas âge ne
peut pas faire 15h à 20h
d'activité.
Le ministre a été clair, il y aura
des situations exceptionnelles
prises en compte.
Mais le principe, c'est de donner
à chacun la chance d'être
accompagné, ce qui n'est pas le
cas aujourd'hui.
On a aujourd'hui plus de la moitié
des bénéficiaires du RSA qui ne
sont pas inscrits à Pôle emploi,
qui ne sont pas inscrits avec un
coach.
Il y a des coaches emploi qui sont
là pour aider à pouvoir passer le
permis de conduire...
Des choses simples qui vont
permettre de remettre le pied à
l'étrier.
- Kathia Gilder: Sur le projet de
loi immigration, a priori, c'est
pour septembre.
C'est une bonne chose pour vous de
diviser, la majorité?
- Violette Spillebout: Je ne pense
pas que ce soit un sujet tabou.
Dans la bouche et la tête des
Français, le sujet immigration
revient très souvent.
A la fois, les Français sont très
préoccupés par les délinquants qui
ne sont pas suffisamment l'objet
d'obligation de quitter le
territoire et de retourner dans
leur pays d'origine.
Et à la fois, tous nos
entrepreneurs sont très préoccupés
de toutes les personnes qui sont
d'origine étrangère qui n'ont pas
le permis de travail et qui
pourtant, ont déjà fait un stage,
un apprentissage, qui correspond à
la compétence dont ils ont besoin.
Ils ne peuvent pas embaucher parce
qu'ils n'en ont pas le droit.
Il y a des situations très
concrètes à résoudre.
C'est très important.
Dans les Hauts-de-France, on a un
grand projet d'aménagement.
C'est 8000 emplois qu'on va devoir
pourvoir sur les travaux publics.
- Kathia Gilder: En attendant,
parlons de cette commission
d'enquête qui vise à faire la
lumière sur les violences commises
lors des manifestations récentes
contre la réforme des retraites ou
encore le projet de mégabassine à
Sainte-Soline.
C'est une demande du groupe
Renaissance.
Les députés en ont validé le
principe.
Voici les explications du
rapporteur et les explications de
l'opposition.
- Nous visons des individus
organisés qui, armés, viennent
pour en découdre avec les forces
de l'ordre.
C'est très clair.
Nous ne visons pas les
organisations syndicales.
Certaines formations politiques ne
dénoncent pas assez fort les
violences.
- Il faut comprendre d'où vient
cette violence aujourd'hui et
cette radicalisation.
Elle vient aussi du fait que notre
pacte démocratique ne va bien.
C'est pas une commission d'enquête
qu'il faudrait, c'est changer de
ministre de l'Intérieur.
- Kathia Gilder: Est-ce que vous
êtes d'accord avec le fait que
cette commission d'enquête vise
uniquement les violences des
casseurs et non pas les violences
de certains policiers qui existent
aussi?
- Violette Spillebout: Il faut pas
se voiler la face.
Vu ce qu'on a vu pendant les
manifestations contre les
retraites, pendant Sainte-Soline,
il y a un vrai sujet qui est
l'influence et l'implication de
l'ultra-gauche, des casseurs, dans
la violence dans les
manifestations.
Et le fait que notre majorité
souhaite cette commission
d'enquête, c'est une chose
nécessaire et que les Français
veulent.
On ne veut plus de casseurs dans
les manifestations.
Après, j'ai échangé avec Florent
Boudié.
C'est lui qui va être rapporteur
dans cette commission d'enquête.
Lui a tenu à entendre nos
oppositions et à ce qu'a
l'occasion de cette commission
d'enquête, on puisse avoir la
lumière sur l'ensemble des
violences.
On a eu un débat à l'Assemblée
nationale mardi dans le cadre de
la semaine de contrôle.
Je suis intervenue sur ce sujet.
On souhaite que la lumière et la
transparence soient faites sur
l'ensemble des violences.
Les proportions de sont pas les
mêmes.
On a une soixantaine d'enquêtes
administratives et pénales contre
des policiers qui auraient commis
des débordements.
Il faut que ces enquêtes soient
suivies, que le Parlement ait
connaissance de l'ensemble de tout
ce qui est fait dans ce cadre.
Mais notre cible principale, ça
reste ces groupuscules structurés
et financés pour infiltrer les
manifestations comme au 1er mai,
devant le cortège, à l'arrière du
cortège.
- Alexandre Poussart: Gérald
Darmanin travaille sur une
nouvelle loi anticasseurs.
Ce serait une bonne idée de
remettre sur la table cette mesure
d'interdiction administrative de
manifester pour certaines
personnes?
- Violette Spillebout: C'est assez
compliqué juridiquement et
constitutionnellement.
Il y a déjà une loi anticasseurs
qui existe.
Je crois que le ministre de la
Justice et le ministre de
l'Intérieur se voient ce vendredi
et vont travailler dans les jours
à venir pour voir s'il faut mieux
renforcer l'application de la loi
anticasseurs ou avoir des mesures
législatives supplémentaires.
La question du contrôle, a priori,
avant les manifestations, sur la
confiscation des armes ou
l'identité de certaines personnes
qui seraient fichées, peut se
poser.
C'est facile dans un stade, c'est
facile aussi dans les
manifestations interdites, de
faire des contrôles et des
confiscations d'armes.
En revanche sur une manifestation
autorisée, la Constitution ne le
permet pas.
Les méthodes changent.
Ils cachent les armes avant.
Tous ces casseurs ont des ressorts
nouveaux.
Il faut qu'on s'adapte.
On a déjà expérimenté les drones
le 1er mai dans beaucoup de lieux
de manifestations.
Ca a évité un incendie grave à la
mairie de Lyon.
Il va falloir qu'on continue de
s'adapter.
- Kathia Gilder: Le contrôleur
général des privations de liberté
a publié un rapport qui critique
des gardes à vue abusives dans des
manifestations.
- Violette Spillebout: Quand on
regarde la tenue de ces
manifestations, on voit bien qu'il
y a des fumigènes, des charges
très fortes contre les policiers.
Le sénateur socialiste qui a passé
quelques jours avec la BRAV-M l'a
constaté.
Il y a des actions rapides, les
arrestations rapides, ensuite,
c'est le rôle du procureur de
faire son travail et de faire le
tri entre des suites pénales qui
doivent être données.
C'est pas à nous de commenter des
décisions de justice.
Pour avoir discuté avec beaucoup
de policiers nationaux, en
particulier à Lille, où c'était un
peu plus calme, et à Paris ces
derniers jours, il y a une
conscience déontologique de la
profession, une conscience de
cette provocation permanente des
casseurs.
Ce qui est le plus grave
aujourd'hui, c'est ce policier
brûlé par un cocktail Molotov.
- Alexandre Poussart: Est-ce que
vous diriez que la justice, dans
ces affaires de violence dans les
manifestations, est laxiste?
- Violette Spillebout: Je crois
que la justice est en train de se
transformer jour après jour.
Il y a aussi un projet de loi de
justice que porte Eric
Dupond-Moretti.
Il travaille avec le ministre de
l'Intérieur sur ce sujet des
casseurs.
Il va falloir qu'on soit efficaces
et qu'on s'adapte à toutes les
nouvelles techniques et à ces
regroupements européens.
Il y a des actions aussi au niveau
des autres pays pour faire en
sorte que ces rassemblements et
ces infiltrations dans les
manifestations ne soient plus
possibles.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le Sénat va
aussi lancer une commission
d'enquête sur le fonds Marianne,
un fonds gouvernemental créé en
2021 par Marlène Schiappa après
l'assassinat de Samuel Paty.
Un fonds pour lutter contre la
radicalisation en ligne.
Le problème, c'est que l'argent de
ce fonds aurait été mal utilisé
par les associations qui en ont
bénéficié.
Notamment pour certaines, à des
fins politiques.
Le parquet national financier a
ouvert une information judiciaire
pour détournement de fonds
publics.
- Les sénateurs de la commission
des finances mèneront bien une
commission d'enquête sur le fonds
Marianne.
Jean-François Husson en sera le
rapporteur.
- Nous avons besoin de comprendre
de quelle manière, à l'issue d'un
événement dramatique, je le
rappelle, l'assassinat barbare de
Samuel Paty, le gouvernement avait
pris des décisions créant un fonds
Marianne.
Aujourd'hui, certaines
informations ont été rendues
publiques.
Notamment sur l'utilisation de ces
fonds.
- Au total, 2,5 millions d'euros
avaient été alloués à 17
associations pour promouvoir les
valeurs de la République.
Selon une enquête conjointe du
magazine Marianne et de France 2,
une des associations qui a touché
355.000 euros aurait créé un site
très peu suivi.
Une autre structure aurait dénigré
plusieurs personnalités
politiques.
- Quand on fait un contre-discourt
républicain et qu'on veut
intéresser les jeunes à la
République, on ne commence pas par
critiquer ses élus.
Il y a là déjà un premier sujet.
Sur la nature des contenus et des
attaques qui ont été proférés, je
crois qu'il y a beaucoup à dire.
Des remarques ont été faites par
des gestionnaires de ce fonds.
Mais sans conséquence,
semble-t-il.
L'ensemble des financements a été
versé.
On n'a pas vu réellement de
changement dans l'attitude de
cette association.
- La commission d'enquête devra
déterminer si Marlène Schiappa, à
l'origine de la création de ce
fonds, a joué un rôle dans cette
attribution aux associations.
- J'ai pas choisi les
associations.
Quelque chose a été dit par
certains responsables LFI, qui ont
dit que j'avais donné de l'argent
à des amis.
Je ne suis amie avec aucun lauréat
du fonds Marianne.
Ces accusations sont difficiles à
démentir.
- La commission d'enquête
commencera ses auditions fin mai.
Elle a trois mois pour rendre ses
conclusions.
- Alexandre Poussart: Avec cette
affaire du fonds Marianne, vous
craignez qu'on se dirige vers un
scandale d'Etat?
- Violette Spillebout: Je crois
que ce qui se passe sur ce fonds
Marianne est très sain.
On a deux démarches parallèles.
Une démarche au Sénat qui vient
d'être votée à l'unanimité, qui
est une commission d'enquête pour
faire la transparence sur
l'attribution des fonds.
C'est très important pour les
Français en général.
- Alexandre Poussart: La semaine
prochaine, ils voteront en
commission d'enquête.
- Violette Spillebout: Quand il y
a des subventions, quand il y a un
jury, des critères, c'est une
nécessité qu'il y ait plus de
transparence.
C'est ce que l'on doit aux
Français.
Il y a une deuxième démarche, la
démarche juridique.
Le parquet national financier est
dans cette démarche.
Une association a signalé un
dysfonctionnement au ministère de
l'Intérieur, qui sur le fondement
du code de procédure pénale, a
lancé cette plainte.
Les choses se font normalement.
On a une ministre qui s'est
expliqué et qui porte plainte pour
diffamation.
On doit réaffirmer notre souci de
transparence, notre lutte aussi
contre les fake news.
On ne peut pas présumer de la
conclusion de la commission au
Sénat et de l'enquête.
- Kathia Gilder: On verra ce que
diront l'enquête et la commission.
Est-ce que vous trouvez tout de
même que Marlène Schiappa est dans
une position confortable pour
exercer sereinement ses fonctions?
- Violette Spillebout: Marlène
Schiappa s'est très clairement
exprimée sur ce sujet.
Je pense que le président de la
commission des finances au Sénat a
lui-même indiqué qu'elle n'était
pas visée personnellement.
Le sujet, c'est de faire la
lumière sur la façon dont sont
attribuées des subventions par
l'Etat à des associations.
C'est sain, je le redis.
- Alexandre Poussart: Le président
de cette commission d'enquête au
Sénat est un ancien sénateur
socialiste.
Vous craignez que les oppositions
tentent de déstabiliser le
gouvernement?
- Violette Spillebout: Je crois à
la probité de l'ensemble des élus
de la République.
On parlait du sénateur socialiste
qui était au sein de la BRAV-M et
qui reconnaissait avec clarté le
travail des policiers, son
jugement partisan.
Quand on est président d'une
commission d'enquête, on fait
sérieusement son travail.
On doit ça aux Français, qu'on
soit socialiste, de la majorité
présidentielle, ou des autres
partis.
- Kathia Gilder: On va finir par
un coup d'oeil à l'agenda de la
semaine prochaine.
- Alexandre Poussart: Mardi, les
sénateurs débattront d'une
proposition de loi pour lutter
contre les dérives des
influenceurs sur les réseaux
sociaux.
Mercredi, ils examineront une
proposition de loi qui vise à
faciliter le passage et
l'obtention du permis de conduire.
- Kathia Gilder: A l'assemblée,
mardi 9 mai, une proposition de
résolution pour inscrire le groupe
Wagner, les mercenaires suspectés
d'agir dans l'ombre de Poutine,
sur la liste des organisations
terroristes.
Et une proposition de loi pour
rendre obligatoires les drapeaux
français et européens
sur les mairies.
- Alexandre Poussart: En quelques
secondes, sur rejetée en
commission.
La majorité présidentielle est
divisée?
- Violette Spillebout: J'en ai
parlé avec le président du groupe
MoDem.
- Kathia Gilder: Il était contre.
- Violette Spillebout: Je pense
que cette proposition sera votée.
Beaucoup de maire le font déjà
aujourd'hui.
Ca nous semble important
symboliquement, le jour de la fête
de l'Europe, que cette proposition
soit votée.
- Alexandre Poussart: C'est la fin
de cette émission.
Merci beaucoup d'avoir été notre
invitée.
Merci à tous.